well,
how about another watcher greeting you with his
brief information for today, wednesday
, july 21, the mandatory use of
masks returns in clark county, however,
not for everyone,
yesterday the commissioners voted
for employees to wear masks
indoors and in public places are
expected  that businesses add
signs for the general public
saying that the use of a mask is
recommended inside the place this order
goes into effect this midnight and will last
until August 17
and if you have not yet been vaccinated and are looking for
where to receive it there will be several  clinics
this week there is one today from 8
am to noon at
fire station number 4 located near
charlestown and 15th street another on thursday from
8 am to noon at
trinity united church then
there will be a hard saturday  a clinic inside the shopping
center number 2 from 11 to 7 at night
and if you want to carry out a
den detection test we also offer you the
he list of places for this week the
three csn establishments will be
offering this service in addition to the
bryn gwyn efe high schools for
a complete list you can visit the
official website of the
southern nevada health district and now we are going to
the weather forecast we will have a
cloudy skies with chances of rain
for tonight this weather will continue
until tomorrow afternoon with an
estimated maximum of 104 degrees the rises
could also appear in the
weekend have a nice sud newspaper hector
mejía and this was your brief news from
william in  Spanish